think the body positivity movement is
positive no I I well it's false body
positivity because it's saying you'll
find the way you are and there is no you
know improve there is no uh they're not
we're not championing Improvement is
what I'm saying okay I think there's a
good point that you made
um but I would like to like draw upon
like the opposite side of that like
obviously with bodied positivity it's
not just about
um like weight it's about like skin
texture skin color yeah but that's like
one of the biggest things I've seen you
you said more between like weight yeah I
don't I don't really see skin texture or
skin color yeah that's marks that kind
of thing or like people that don't shave
people are hairier yeah I mean
I don't want to see that yeah why are
they putting that I miss the days when
models would make me feel bad about
myself and I would put their picture on
the treadmill and I'd start running yeah
I had to bring them back
I think you've got to find a balance
because if you go to the other end of
the spectrum and someone's really
underweight and it's being advertised
it's it's not gonna that's not so great
I think you are you will ultimately
ultimately you are fine the way you are
because I don't think no one can tell
you anything obviously if you're having
these health issues then definitely
needs to be addressed but um
yeah to be honest with you so you think
you'll find the way you are at 300
pounds not necessarily you're not I do
think you should you should definitely
do something about that but I think it's
about being realistic if these types of
things are being shown on media then I
think it should be shown in a way to
show that listen
whether it's bad or good uh there are
people like this and they're still part
of society etc etc it doesn't it doesn't
on it doesn't deem you uh
a certain way in a negative way if that
makes sense don't you think it
normalizes it
because shouldn't obesity not be normal
shouldn't it be abnormal isn't that what
we should want I think obesity shouldn't
be the norm but I do feel like there are
people that are just going to be bigger
there's people are going to be smaller
regardless like if we put everyone on
the same diet people will still do
different sizes because they're like
morbidly beats I did say like not obese
I say like people are going to be
different sizes I think
um it'd be interesting if body's
positively went in the in the way in the
direction that we're like okay they're
going to be people that are different
sizes and they're still a part of
society they still should be respected
we still need to treat them like humans
I think that's kind of what the
direction it should have gone in instead
of like normalizing um being more
believe obese I think that's what your
point but I think people will say when
you say all shapes and sizes they will
put in morbidly obese like that's fine
unless you explicitly say acceptablely
obese but then you'll be you know shamed
for fat shaming no like I mean
like genetically like you're going to be
shorter I might be taller someone might
be I don't I don't want to say the use
the term big boned because it doesn't
really make sense but some people are
going to be broader and have one of
their shoulders like this is like the
reason why a lot of people pursue
different sports
um you just built different you know
regardless of diet and how how you train
you can't really change your genetics by
that much some people achieve certain
muscle formations that certain people
won't have yeah I want to show you guys
um something that I saw on Twitter today
I'm gonna blessing and this is I'm going
to send it to you you may send it on
Instagram
yeah because it's an extra one I don't
think it's like normal to the extent
here let me
uh okay
okay I saw a picture on Twitter today
that was like a beach from the 70 or
like it was before the 70s maybe 60s 50s
and obesity really wasn't normal then if
you go to a third world country it's not
normal even even like there weren't even
really overweight people
um and so I feel like
when you put them on the cover of
magazines it's like you're saying find
like find me attractive you must find me
attractive and when you're like uh not
really like I wouldn't want to look like
that ever at all not even a little bit
and they they say your body shaming but
it's just like honest do you know what I
have more issue with I don't really have
an issue with putting someone that's
large on in front of a magazine I have
more of an issue with like the
Magazine's intentions because a lot of
these big magazines have promoted like
hyper skinny or underweight women for
like the past 10 years the past decades
before and then just to put a larger one
in front of the magazine all of a sudden
is like yeah let's just forget all the
past women we promoted before and this
is the new standard of beauty I don't
really like that kind of narrative where
like okay we're just gonna switch up now
and this is what we support when that's
really not what they're about
what do you what do you mean because
like let's say you use like like Marilyn
Monroe she wasn't underweight and she
was like a pinnacle of beauty
yeah but she's like one woman yeah I
think that's the exception not the rule
when it comes to everybody had that
hourglass figure that's why it's so
iconic yeah I feel like that was like
because of the fashion at the time if
you look at the kind of the dresses that
they wear it's very like skirts are very
high-waisted and it's very tight at this
point I think it's more to the fashion
than emulating this type of style
also the body type followed if you look
more towards the 80s the more sporty
wears when they were a bit more like
fitter and more athletic looking I think
we kind of the bodies followed the
fashion so like now you can see like low
waisted clothing coming into fashion
women are going to want to be a bit more
Skinner skinnier or thinner you see Kim
Kardashian taking her implants out to
follow that kind of fashion trend that's
going to come in I don't even wow okay
yeah like Y2K you might have heard of it
like a lot of that kind of fashion is
coming back so a lot of people are going
to try and be skinnier to match that
fashion I think like fashion and the way
people want to dress and look like kind
of follow each other
yeah yeah but and it's silly because why
change your body for a micro Trend just
be healthy you know but it's it's how
it's how it goes I just think hourglass
has always been like Maryland like even
if you look at Audrey Hepper and there's
another like I like I think it's not I
think I have to waste ratio yeah it can
be very thin and still have an hourglass
figure because you've got really wide
hips and a small like rib cage yeah
but you're not going to be like Marilyn
Monroe Marilyn Robles uh no I I agree
with you I think he wasn't very thin but
she had that shape yeah like I think
there's a difference between
like you know saying like we have
different body types but either way like
no no one's turning down Jennifer
Aniston and she's built more like Square
she was a pinnacle of Beauty in the
early 2000s she's not she doesn't have
that hourglass you know shape but you
know in the same era like Kim
Kardashian's also beautiful like I think
it's just like thin thinner oh this is
the picture from like the like look at
it there's not really obesity back then
everyone's ball in what is this in
America is there a picture of Are You
Gonna Do Is there is there more than one
I thought there was like three
oh that would have been good to have a
contrast but everybody kind of looks the
same
yeah that's what I'm saying like
everyone was thin for the most part so
it's almost like we're normalizing
something that shouldn't be normal
and saying find me a try like that's
another issue is that people that are
overweight feel like they can't be made
fun of just like everyone else oh
something crazy happened to me the other
day so I was in like a market in
Greenwich and I wanted to buy some jeans
and I was like there's like a way of
trying them on like using your neck to
see if it fits your waist it's like a
cool hack like you go around your neck
and if it fits yeah I've seen that if
it's you interesting and I end up buying
these jeans and like they fit in the
rooms like oh they look great on you I
was like oh perfect I'm gonna buy them
and I'm walking away and the woman
shouts I hate skinny people
so imagine like I was just thinking yeah
yeah like in a joke way but like I just
thought to myself like no one really
makes the reverse of that joke I know
it's like cliche yeah you say I hate fat
people people be like yeah like no one
battered an eyelid yeah but I feel like
we've really normalized I don't know
like
these back like side comments towards
women that are a lot thinner and I feel
like we can't really talk about people
that um are obese the same way as we
used to the transparency is gone I feel
everything's sugar-coated now anyways
yeah I feel like if When someone tells
you oh like you've lost weight like
it still has that same
I just feel like it's the same way as
saying oh like you're fat now I'd be
like oh I'd feel a bit like insecure
like no my parents don't really hold
back I'm not gonna lie me either I'm
like
I feel like it was good for me though
like I I think I would have been like
I've always been the type to like
struggle like I've had to work really
hard because I eat really bad like I'm
an athlete so it kind of evens out but
like
like honestly my mom when I was younger
would she would she would fast shoot me
a little bit she'd be like oh you got
your but honestly like it hurt at the
time but I'm so glad she did I got on
the treadmill
I think there's definitely something
that is important of like a parent being
like honest with that like Sono daughter
especially if they get into like a place
that's unhealthy
I think
um
it's a shame because a lot of children
are abuse like obese and childhood never
really lose um will stay obese for the
rest of their life and then they have
problems with diabetes they die earlier
and I feel like if that was just
addressed like when they were young if
that honestly like like your mother like
maybe not fat shaming but just you know
I'm gonna help you with your health that
conversation with her I think it would
really improve like just Health in
general I feel like fat chamber was the
best way to do it you look fat if it
comes from a place of love then why not
if it's someone you know you may not
know then it's just like sorry how dare
you but if it's someone like if your
family yeah yeah of course like why why
not it's the truth it's not like because
being fat I mean it's not it doesn't
have to be
negative like unless you're obese and
you have actual health problems
ultimately
perhaps you need to change stomach in
your life if you feel like you're
gaining too much weight if someone's
telling you oh like listen I feel like
um you've put on a bit too much or it's
just like oh yeah no I know I know I've
realized as well it's nothing it's
nothing
um too personal you shouldn't feel so
attacked
okay blessing do the second clip
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible